first of all congratulations you have
become become one of the hottest
comedians in the business and you are
everywhere right now I I Drive around LA
you've probably seen this too your
billboards are all over the city for
different projects not even for the same
one that's right so it's all as you
imagined it right that seems strange to
you at all no no it just took a little
while but yeah I thought I'd release
everything in one hour right you're
having a very intense moment of fame and
you but you've you've you've planned it
out very carefully all right
driving around you've got this HBO
special billboard which is massive okay
that's an entire building I think I
passed that every day and this is gonna
sound like a weird lie I'm not friends
with Ellen DeGeneres but she that sounds
like a lie in itself just the way I look
but I thought you were all friends yeah
what do you mean I've never noticed your
accent before yeah so but she hunted my
phone number down she called me on
Saturday and she saw that billboard too
and I was like this is a weird phone
call you get a call it's the phone rings
that's own DeGeneres and she's saying I
saw your billboard there was more to the
conversation every building yeah Betsy's
number she called me four Pepsi's number
and then this Netflix documentary
billboard that's so that's a completely
different billboard that's really
impressive yeah and and then I also have
a billboard for an action film you do
yeah which one is that I don't know
about that oh that's Mission Impossible
is that not me
[Applause]
you look
I honestly I don't know anymore I don't
know maybe I did an action film yeah
yeah that's the level of your heat
mm-hmm
do you get mistaken for Tom Cruise ever
constantly would think so